122 championne ne tient qu'à un fil
suspendue au dessus du vide capucine
exécute les figures imposées avec
maîtrise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
difficile de garder l'équilibré car la
pression est grande
l'athlète rouennaise de 12 ans met la
barre très haut pour sa toute première
participation à ces championnats de
france élite
son objectif certains dionne c'était sur
le podium ça donne quoi par la suite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour y arriver la gymnaste aujourd'hui
en pôle espoir en région parisienne
s'entraîne plus de 20 heures par semaine
championnats d'europe gio ses
entraîneurs fonde beaucoup d'espoir en l
[Musique]
acrobate
il faut faire des vrilles en attend
beaucoup de choses comme ça
à l'image de capucine quelques jeunes
gymnastes normands sont prometteurs mais
côté compétition de haut niveau sur
treize grandes régions françaises la
normandie se classe seulement en milieu
de tableau et ce malgré l'attrait de la
discipline qui compte 24 mille licenciés
toute la politique du haut niveau elle
s'est calé sur des pôles espoirs paul
france que nous on a pas sur le
territoire
forcément ça a mené un décalage mais
aujourd'hui on a des clubs en lien avec
le comité qui se structure et donc on
est en train de monter petit à petit des
générations qui sont porteuses pour la
suite
capucine ne montera pas sur le podium
cette fois ci
qu'importe ces nouvelles générations
d'athlètes en sont bien conscientes
il faut continuer sa route tenir son
objectif pour aller toujours plus vite
plus haut plus fort c'est la devise des
jeux olympiques
ouais